[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance events forced me to conclude
there is already enough about the Trump
campaigns June 9th 2016 meeting with the
Russians that is publicly known admitted
to and/or reported to justify the arrest
of Donald Trump jr. Jared Kushner and
Paul Manafort today and to justify the
impeachment conviction and removal of
Donald Trump as president tomorrow and
Trump has now jumped on this bandwagon
beginning to rationalize that conspiring
with an enemy nation is just politics
while one of his own lawyers has
inadvertently opened the door to the
prospect that Trump may have been
directly involved with that meeting or
even have attended it for the email
chain released by Trump jr. the man
setting up the meeting specifically
states that the Russians quote offered
to provide the Trump campaign with some
official documents and information that
would incriminate Hillary and that it is
quote part of Russia and its
government's support for mr. Trump Trump
jr. arranged a meeting at which he
agreed to receive what he believed was
official Russian government information
and support for the Trump campaign the
June 9th meeting was as far as the Trump
campaign knew a meeting with an emissary
of the Russian government / Federal
Election Commission filings the
president's campaign paid $50,000 to one
of Trump juniors attorneys two weeks
before the bezel mid sky a story broke
this would be legal if and only if the
attorney was working on campaign matters
by all accounts the June 9th meeting to
conspire with Russian emissaries was a
trump campaign meeting / the email
timeline Trump jr. confirmed the meeting
on June 7th 2016 at 6:14 p.m. Eastern
Time
2 hours and 59 minutes later Trump
himself apparently surprised his own
staff by announcing during a speech that
he would give another speech the
following week revealing how Clinton's
quote her up
dealings gave quote favorable treatment
to other governments including quote the
Russians
if Trump did not know on June 7th of his
sons planned meeting with the Russian
and go-betweens on June 9th his sudden
announcement bordered on clairvoyance /
the New York Times and not directly
denied by the White House
Trump juniors initial false statement
dismissing the conspiracy as a meeting
about adoptions was drafted aboard Air
Force One by presidential advisors and
signed off on by Trump himself the July
8th 2017 statement covering up the truth
of the Russian conspiracy was a White
House cover-up for the Trump attorney
Jay Sekulow the appropriateness of the
June 9th meeting and those who attended
it was reviewed by the Secret Service
quote if this was nefarious why did the
Secret Service allow these people in the
President had Secret Service protection
at that point unquote he did indeed
however Trump jr. did not as of June 9th
2016 participants in meetings even
meetings involving Trump family members
would not have been vetted by the Secret
Service the only reason the Secret
Service would or should have been at a
meeting on June 9th 2016 was if Donald
Trump himself was directly and
personally affected by that meeting or
if Donald Trump himself knew about that
meeting or Donald Trump himself had
asked them to vet the people at that
meeting or if Donald Trump himself
I personally attended that meeting one
of the president's own attorneys has now
opened up the possibility that Trump
himself attended the conspiracy meeting
with Trump jr. Matta Fort Kushner and
the Russians or at minimum has raised
the question of how else Trump might
have been directly involved or affected
by the meeting and the seemingly
treacherous business conducted at the
June 9th 2016 meeting directly involved
Trump's son Trump's son-in-law
and Trump's soon-to-be campaign chairman
believing they would be receiving dirt
on their opponent from the Russian
government by a middlemen
and Trump's own lawyer now raises the
possibility Trump himself was somehow
directly and immediately involved enough
that if it were nefarious the Secret
Service would have prevented the meeting
Donald Trump's conduct relative to the
June 9 2016 meeting before the election
thus may include crimes of conspiracy
and effectual if not legally literal
espionage and disloyalty to the United
States of America
Donald Trump's conduct relative to the
June 9th 2016 meeting after the election
specifically the production of Trump
juniors false statement by White House
staff on July 8th 2017 that may
constitute obstruction of justice Trump
jr. Kushner mana fort perhaps the
Russians perhaps others should be
arrested today they will not be Donald
Trump should be impeached tomorrow he
will not be but that this end game is
approaching inevitably can be discerned
not just by the guilty actions of Trump
and his son and the others but by the
suddenly shifting defenses from Trump
apologists who still place party and
power ahead of country Fox News and the
right-wing media had begun to float the
collusion is not really a crime defense
from host Greg Jarrett
as early as the 23rd of May Sean Hannity
tried it on June 23rd Brit Hume on June
25th Jeanine Pirro July 15th and finally
Trump himself on July 17th most
politicians would have gone to a meeting
like the one Don junior attended in
order to get info on an opponent that's
politics on July 16th had come Trump
Attorney Sekulow is dubious damning
defense that the Secret Service would
have stopped a conspiratorial meeting
with the Russians even though the only
person in the building then under Secret
Service protection was Donald Trump
himself no Trump jr. Kushner mana four
and the others will not be arrested
today and Trump will not be impeached
tomorrow but for those who still defend
the clear and present menace to our
freedoms that is Donald Trump and for
those who fear our political system will
never be able to rid us of him there is
a startling number buried inside the
latest Washington Post ABC
News poll 58% of Americans disapprove of
Trump's presidency 60% of us believe the
Russians tried to influence the outcome
of the vote that elected him but still
just 41 percent of Americans believe
Trump campaign members intentionally
helped the Russians to influence the
election
well more correctly only 41% believed
that the surveying for that poll closed
on Thursday July 13th before Trump
indicated maybe he had heard about the
meeting longer ago than just a few days
earlier before it turned out Trump jr.
had lied and there were two other
Russians at that meeting before Sekulow
inadvertently raised the question of why
the Secret Service guarding only trump
protecting only Trump looking out for
only trump would have been betting a
meeting Trump did not attend the Trump
gang leaks like a sieve it cannot keep a
story straight if used truth only as one
of a series of escapes and it is being
pursued by the most skilled crime
fighters in the world the percentage of
Americans who believe Trump campaign
members intentionally helped the
Russians to influence our election was
just 41 percent last Thursday that
number will not decline it will grow and
fast or slow soon or late it will grow
large enough to end this damnable
presidency resist remove peace